while Ruth Davidson has been credited
with leading the resurgence of the
Conservative Party in Scotland and
without Scottish MPs the Tories would
actually have lost the last election so
little wonder perhaps that she's been
tipped as a future prime minister
something she ruled out in the last week
so let's find out why and welcome thanks
very much for being with us thank you
as we started we was talking to the
party chairman Brian Lewis and before
earlier on in the programme about this
security breach it could be quite
serious couldn't it I mean in a time
when after school discourse is so toxic
have you've received any calls from any
pranksters well no but then I didn't put
my mobile number in the app but to be
honest yeah I think there was an issue
there it's been resolved it got resolved
very quickly and but people don't have
to have your mobile number to be toxic
to you you can see that through social
media every day so yes of course the
party is going through all of the
appropriate information and remedies
that are there and it is embarrassing
there's no getting away from that but it
was identified early it was fixed
quickly and then we move on but let's
move on and we spread of course is the
big issue going into the contacted party
conference you campaign very strongly
for remain in that referendum now the
only credible proposal on the table
we're told is the checkers arrangement
and something that Boris Johnson's
described just arranged something that
the EU that have said will not work if
it was a choice between No Deal and a
second referendum would you support a
second referendum well first of all I
think I need to address the premise of
your question because yes there are
areas of impasse between the EU and the
United Kingdom government position but
we know that that we're working on that
and after Saltzburg
and blow-up which slightly cleared the
air actually we know that officials are
working very closely together from the
UK in the Irish side with proposals in
the Irish backstop and also between the
UK and the EU sites to
look at the impasse of the economic
agreement so I think there still the
basis there for a deal to be done and
and I would always prefer there to be a
deal than no deal but when it comes to
rerunning referendums I would be an
enormous hypocrite if I say it just
because there was one that I had lost as
a remainder and we should immediately
read on it when I spent four years in
Scotland seeing Nicola Sturgeon
shouldn't get another one on
independence because that's one that I
want so I'm not actually an agreement
that we need to have another referendum
would you prefer to see No Deal then
then let's think I'm a friend well I
think there's a false choice that you're
giving us because there is a deal that's
on the table that everyone is working
towards and we saw really Foster's is it
because he was in Maine is said that
she's the chair to see No Deal than a
bad deal so she's spoken over the
possibility of no deal the government
has been releasing you know it's
preparations for no deal it's not
something that I'm just putting up my
back pocket it's something that we are
criticized the government for for as
people where earlier this year for not
doing enough preparations for the
possibility of your deal and then
criticized them for doing preparations
for an ordeal and as you say the Prime
Minister's choice is between a deal or
no deal not between some form of deal or
you know another referendum that's not
what's on the table what's on the table
as a credible set of proposals we're a
long way towards getting agreement there
are two areas of in us and I think it
behoves the government and the EU to try
and make sure we deliver for the people
of all of our respective countries and
that means trying to resolve these areas
of impasse we've got a very tight time
schedule before the next EU summit in
October and but I think there's a dealer
to be done and I support the Prime
Minister in getting it and I think part
of what the party should be doing is
giving her the space to get in and get
the job done and I think perhaps some of
the noises off perhaps need to count out
calling the deal deranged that's
probably not
you know I mean I don't particularly use
language like that when I'm discussing
areas or you know geopolitics and I
don't think that is why sorta do but
what I think is strange about some of
the attacks that are in the newspaper
today is this is someone who was
praising what the Prime Minister brought
home in terms of moving on to the next
stage last December someone who was in
you know of one of the great officers of
state who was sitting ringing the
cabinet table who know says that he was
in some way deceived no I don't sit
around the cabinet evil I'm not in
government I do attend political cabinet
but I knew what was on what was being
said in design but I'm not quite sure
who their former foreign secretary
didn't so it's easy a hypocrite you know
I think that what's interesting in
today's coverage is he seems to be
spending an awful lot of time talking
about his London mayoral ship and very
little time in fact he's not even
mentioned the fact he was foreign
secretary for two years and was in the
room helping to influence this and
indeed was praising it as as you know
soon ago as December now after the
referendum in July 2016 you said in an
interview I want to stay in the single
market even if the consequence of that
is maintaining free movement to play
them so is that still do what was being
asked about you know where my position
was in regards to all of the different
options on the table and I'm a remainer
you know I would have stayed in the EU
if that was the option and that's what I
voted for and if they're aware to be
another referendum not I support one I
would vote for that again but we do have
to respect the Democratic Monday of the
the biggest electoral event we've ever
had in this country you know I'm 17 and
a half million people voted for
something that I didn't walk for but we
do say they have to honor that but but
you can still honor it by going further
Norway model for example where we'd be
outside of the EU but still within the
single market
you would prefer really well I think the
issue that we have with that is what was
it that people were voting for when they
voted to leave well I I took part in a
huge number of debates up and down the
country some of them televised some of
them um you know in ten holes and all
the rest of it and was continually being
challenged by those on the other side
about this idea that in some way and
voting leave would get in the way of
trade and one of the main proponents
arguments on the other side was that we
would be able to say in free trade deals
with other countries now if we see in a
customs union that's not something that
we're they were able to do it also means
that any trade deals that the EU strikes
would apply to us and we wouldn't be
able to be part of deciding what's in
them so so you know I I do think one of
the issues with the referendum was that
it was a quite a short campaign and we
didn't explore all these options before
the vault but I mean I think I would
find it quite hard to argue that wasn't
something that was laid out by the other
site now we've been talking about brexit
in this issue in this interview and
Theresa maybe Boris Johnson about Forex
again today does it worry you that all
the bandwidth if you like in the
Conservative Party is being occupied by
brexit and there isn't enough big
thinking going on on some of the other
issues the domestic issues are really
important that you're going to set on
the doorstep I think I think one of the
things that we're trying to do in this
conference is to talk about practically
delivering for people and that's why you
see the announcements that we brought Oh
have been about building more homes
helping young people get on the housing
ladder well I think the timing of this
is you know we are four or five weeks
before the EU summit breaks it is always
going to dominate and indeed your
questions to me so far have all been
about that because it's the big issue of
the D but don't think that the UK
government is not getting on with the
job because they are and they're
committed to doing so
but I do think we also have to prepare
ourselves for a post brexit sort of
national narrative what is the UK in the
world and people are asking these
questions and and I would like to think
that I'm gonna be one of the people that
can help contribute to that debate and
to show that we are a country that
shoulders our burden in the world that
you know we're one of the people that
make sure that the global rules apply
and that we help others through our soft
power we've just returned for the first
time in a number of years to being the
highest and most influential soft power
country in the world and and that's
I think you see the government looking
at things like the festival of Britain
and all of these other areas and now
you've written a book called yes she
cannot quite keen to talk to you about
as well and it's all about celebrating
women's achievement both so it's it's to
come out 100 years after the first women
got the vault and it talks about how far
we've come but actually quite a crucial
part of it is how we've still got that
next steps yeah no do you think Theresa
May I mean in a way she symbolizes
exactly that she know she shows how far
we've come but do you think she also
shows how far we've got to go I mean do
you think that she's had a hard time as
Prime Minister because she's warming
well actually she's one of the women
that splits in the book hello meat
interviewer and and she talks herself
about the work that she's done in
setting up and women to win which is a
conservative proposal to get more women
into politics it's a nonpartisan time
[ __ ] there's also the head of the tea
you see in the co-founder of the women's
equality party and and other political
women that non-political women in there
as well
so do you think has had a harder time
and I think anyone that would be dealing
with an issue as big and as complex as
brexit which had divided the country and
and binary referendums always do would
be under severe criticism at the moment
and we'd be shouldering quite a heavy
burden in an office and I think we
probably would even know until after it
you know the dust settles and were a
long way past that we'll look back and
see just how impressive and how
resilient that she's been during this
time and I think some of the colour and
some of the cartoons in the commentary
do absolutely pick up on her feminine
see and the fact that she's a woman and
it's not harder than the David Cameron
got with some of the cartoons about him
or Tony Blair I'm not so sure and now
it's a very personal book isn't it you
talk about your own experiences with
depression yeah actually I found it
quite to put read and that
about you know trying to punish yourself
punching walls cutting her stomach
cutting your arms I mean how difficult
was that pier to go and also why did you
decide to write about it that way yeah
well it's I mean it happened quite long
time ago so it's first diagnosed with
clinical depression at 18 when I was at
University and um I think looking back
on that period no so that's all were 20
years ago you know we didn't really talk
about it very much there and I didn't
have much information I didn't have
anyone in the public eye I really
thought that it was a field stopped all
of my dreams and ambitions that every
every 18 year olds has and I remember
speaking to three years ago to one of
the really big mental health charities
and spoke with about wanting to be able
to talk about that so that hopefully it
helps someone else who's in a police
know that I was back then to know that
it's not a food stop to your life and
it's not as if sometimes talks about
something that happens and then is fixed
that it's something that you have
ongoing management with and and it would
have really helped me you know if I had
somebody in the public eye seeing and
we've got you know Prince Harry and
we've got sports stars we've got
business people seeing it and I've not
heard that many people from politics
seeing it and it's taken me this amount
of time to kind of work up the courage
and find a vehicle where I could tell it
in my own words and not have it
distorted through the lens of
journalists like yourself not having an
unexamined life something that's been
preying on my mind for some time and I
think if I ever got to the point and I
hope I've got a number of years in me as
a Scottish Conservative leader and if I
ever got to the point where I left
office and I'd never spoken about it I
think I think I would feel as if I had
done something wrong or done a
disservice or or maybe maybe just not
being brave enough or not not done
enough you know in in the book as well
you talk about that famous new
statements one article where they talked
about
women with children and while it's a few
women with children had reached the top
of context a new right that you're still
in the gray area and saying that you
have no idea how changing family
responsibilities will affect the way I
do my job insider media do you are you
worried about that do you think that
having a child might impact your career
well I'm to be honest I'm four weeks to
go until my due to eat so I think rather
than worrying about how the child will
affect the job I'm worried about how the
job will affect the child's because
because you know in terms of priorities
at the moment making sure this one comes
into the world and in a you know with
ten fingers ten toes it's kind of the
top of the list but you know it's that
party line you ruled out running for the
top job as well no I mean I've been
seeing that for about thirty four years
since David Cameron very kindly tipped
me as a potential successor and it's
been hanging around my neck ever since
there and I know what my job is and it's
in Scotland and I know what I want to do
and I want to be the first conservative
First Minister of Scotland and and I
want to do that you know in my hometown
of Edinburgh and where I've got I'm not
just the the job that I want and I'm
ambitious for the country but I've also
got all of the other things that the
matter in life you know my loved ones my
family my friends my child hopefully
around me and but but I'm sort of long
enough in the tooth to know that there
are some things that I won't be able to
control until I know what it's like so
we've got plan you know we've got a plan
for you know me taking a bit of time off
and then go back to work and all the
rest of it but but we've built in a lot
of flexibility because like thousands of
women across Britain I just don't know
how it's going to quite work and I need
to ask you as somebody who played such a
leading robot role in the debates during
the referendum do sports guys campaign
to see an independent commission well in
in Scotland's you know we have multiple
debates for every election I've fought
six elections and two referenda in seven
years so we have them all of the time so
I'm certainly I'm well up for any sort
of fight but in terms of having to
create a Crangle to decide something
that's gonna happen three-and-a-half
years from now I think in terms of the
pressing questions under the UK it's a
little bit further down the list but you
you're
Rhoda bass it's not silly it's not what
I do I do them quite often and I've
never shied away from a fight in my life
okay David thank you very much